welcome to this video yeah this is the
final coverage for the gas room of
Memorial around 10 the last round of
this tournament and it sees a real
decider at the end Carlton playing
karana they both have a plus to score
koala had lost one game and 13 well
Towson has this crazy tournament with
two wins at the start then two losses
then two wins again really weird he am I
beat mamedyarov and nakamura two times
and but lost two games and one gave me
lost two Kirwan and the first turn of
the tournament so this is them but far
most interesting pairing in the last
round was it the most interesting game
probably yes so I'm going to cover it
the other two games ended in draws and
we had mamedyarov playing kayaking this
was in fact a very sharp game in in the
English hedgehog or English double
fianchetto also interesting not so
interesting was Nakamura a job of we are
quite surprisingly road job of late the
Berlin on the real Lopez building ball
and nakamura never got anything going
and it was a draw after a real large
number of moves but they're really never
happened anything the only remarkable
thing was I'll put this on the board
just because it was very funny i think
it's not so important really here
starting here we are moved 24 yeah i'd
just briefly look at the whole position
it's a typical type of middle game
position from the berlin wall why it has
nothing much and now look what black is
doing rook h6 rogue h5 rook h8
rogue age five roo gadget so have a look
at the right hand side here we've got
five rook moves in a row just look on
the right hand side what the rock is
doing yeah yeah and only here 25 moves
later with Bishop d7 this rook stopped
moving this must be some sort of record
nah 24 moves in a row with the same
piece in a position where only um
they're very little has been exchanged
it's not like there is just one piece to
move there's the whole BOTS to move but
yeah it was all the all the rook 25
moves okay so just a funny episode by
the way let's see the pawn structure
never changed and move 77 i think it was
it was 50 the 50 move rule was in effect
moved 27 the last pound poor move and 77
a draw yeah and no idea there was simply
nothing happening here um Oh game so
Kasich arowana the game of the round d4
Knight f3 slightly curious why neither
three yeah they all play see for here
but Carlton has an interesting idea
let's see please g3 here yeah jaicko
wanna plays a quick c5 yeah council has
delayed the move c4 and it's I think in
most cases there is not much relevance
to that but here after karana has played
c5 it actually gets interesting because
here Carson didn't play the normal move
which would be c4 but you went for
see 3 yeah is this a passive move it
looks a bit looks a bit weak but it's
not really a passive move it has some
quite original ideas um black now must
be very cautious in a way with this next
move because we'll see three white shows
his intention to take on c5 and in some
cases this would really be really really
important group where black is not so
easily getting it back I can show you a
sample line of black castles for example
what can think of taking here and it's
not really clear that black will get
this back 9 a-6 and then there is this B
form and there's possibly Bishop e3 both
moves are interesting yeah something
like this leads to a fairly a fairly
weird position but interesting position
so this is a very important moment
should black allow the capture or what
what should he do the easiest solution
in this position but rejected by corona
is to just take here after which white
will recapture with the pawn and then
leg place the symmetrical move d5 this
is a position that normally arises from
a different new order of course and the
move order would be something like that
yeah the fianchetto boon felt with an
exchange on d5 but this has one very
distinct problem for black it's almost
impossible to ever win it's it is
slightly very slightly more comfortable
for white black has excellent equalizing
chances but it's a very dry position and
maybe not not the type of position
that koala wanted to play so he played d
5 which is a very sharp move in a way as
it also allows the capture and yeah
cousin just took it and this is a very
sharp now black it's not easily getting
the pawn back we can look at various
ideas to to get it back quickly but
white always has those camera moves
before we should be three it's not easy
at all to get it back yeah Kara wanna
plate castles first castles and a five
this is probably the right way to play
it's very difficult to get it back at
all if you don't play a five and move
like night a six for example now I'm
trying to take it what will probably
really play before and I'm absolutely
not sure how black should get the pawn
back it's it's really not a great
compensation here for this pawn so if
I've seems right to me preventing or
making it much more difficult to play
before we're white yeah it should be
three played you're developing this
piece possibly going here covering c5
and ya know black must decide how to get
the porn back and in fact the
interesting choice baccarat wanna was to
not get the porn back home at all at for
the moment which I found quite surprised
he played knight c6 just continuing to
develop it's not terribly bad but I
still was quite surprised to see that um
for me the really most normal muthiya
would have been nice for attacking the
bishop yeah most likely the bishop needs
to move the most obvious choice
is my book special deform and then i
guess ii five is the only move that
makes some sense now aged three funny
motif now we have this exchange here and
this is one possible line at first you
think okay well this is what the six
points five points isn't wide upon up
yes but after something like night a six
black has a very good compensation
because of this very strong bishop on g7
he's got the bishop pal and something
like that is just very active for black
the good night IAM and especially this
g10 bishop is very strong so this should
be a quite a good compensation instead
of Bishop g4 of course white has other
moves he can play Bishop f4 which is not
trying to exchange the bishop on g7
immediately after that black can go for
9 a-6 again trying to to get this back
it's a possible continuation but 94 will
win the porn back so this was an
interesting alternative and I thought
really the better alternative after
knight c6 he's not getting the porn back
and I really don't see a big
compensation here Quincy want is a
strong move it prepares to centralize
the rook here set up this rook queen
opposition possibly followed by a c4 yes
logical if I have black needs to get
some sort of play for the pawn rook t1
and Queenie seven okay can I be five
heading for this very juicy square
Bishop you 695 yeah this is a concrete
play attacking the bishop p.m.
Bishop g4 and 96 this was very nicely
played by cards and this is a very
strong night obviously on d6 and here as
it in this moment yes here karana played
age 6 at first I couldn't really
understand what is this was Bishop takes
e2 why I didn't black take him in fact
white has a very strong response Luke
takes d5 that's very strong very strong
if black now takes a look after the
simple Bishop recapture we see that
absolute here four pieces are directed
towards f7 and black cannot cover this
the only cover I have seven is night to
d8 after which Queen c2 and queen e for
leads to an absolutely a dominating
position of whites pieces it's quite a
remarkable position one of the most
active piece placements that that I can
recall Black is in a terrible shape so
this is why Bishop takes e2 wasn't a
really great idea as rook takes d5 is
simply possible you played age 6 kicking
the night away and now King to age 78
336 and before yeah this is all fairly
fairly normal looking at it I think
before some trying to support the extra
pawn on c5 it gains space and yeah black
basically only can exchange on b3 now he
cannot keep the position closed allowing
by this extra point without any any sort
of trouble so he took them and played
924 yeah and blacks position is okay
he's not in a big trouble the thing is
we are already talking about very small
margins for error
the position that black has does not
tolerate any inaccurate play and after
92 we got we get to a to a key position
of the game in fact this is already this
is the most important position of the
game by far yeah what should like do
widest obviously threatening to take on
a form winning upon with them with an a
decisive advantage so black needs to do
something with the e4 night he decided
to play the moose f5 after some
relatively long thought and it turns out
that this is really not working out at
all and the better move it seems to be
is to take on d6 and after seat XD 6 not
to capture on the six but to play 27 i'm
pretty sure that he had calculated that
queer queen takes by the way is very
good for white after night see for this
is just showing this nice replacement on
the d file yeah here black has problems
it's just one possible line that is
excellent for white there are many
others but the general problem is that
this combination of the night coming
here the bishop coming here and the
pressure on d5 almost certainly will it
cost the d5 pawn and white has an
excellent position really on top of that
yeah but the point is black does not
need to take he can play Queen d7 and
this type of move you can easily
overlook or completely a judge judge
wrongly wrong Lisa so what mm-hmm okay
miss judge yeah what is blacks idea he
wants to get the porn back of course but
he lays this possibly getting it by
Bishop f-86 or
taking with the Queen but at a later
stage and in general this ship seems to
be okay for black for example just to to
continue the line of white play
something like this covering the d6 bond
then black will play you form this is a
very important resource that frees up
this bishop and it blunts the g2 bishop
yeah it's only looking at this e4 pawn
and black can continue with moves like a
five later and maybe rook to c8 trying
to attack the c5 Bishop it's probably
some time until you get the pawn back
but blackheads quite quite a nice active
position I think after that this is
probably what you should have done he
played f5 however and this leads to huge
trouble cards not took on e4 with the d2
night and he takes he was played yeah
FTC form it's not helping at all the
problem is that after Queen B one white
is putting quite some pressure on the e4
pawn which at the moment looks
ridiculous why would you have a welcome
how should white ever take this pawn
because there's always the cover from d5
but the problem is white is going to
play C form in the very near future and
after that the deep on will move and
then e 4 drops for example let's just
put a move on the board black is playing
something like that then you play with
c4 yeah threatening to take deform
Bishop drops back and now you see e4 has
attacked three times and you have
absolutely no way to protect the pawn
yeah you can push forward but this is
also costs upon and white is just just
winning him at the end here will always
have the e4 square as well so an
excellent position
this is the problem as f take semen and
so this is why he took with the with the
deep on but this is obviously not ideal
as well now White has three points
against one and if black is just doing
nothing carbon plate Queen B 1 preparing
the beep on push if black is just doing
nothing white will convert the three
pawns against one on the queenside so
it's absolutely mandatory for black to
get active now on the kingside he's got
this five against four majority and has
most of his pieces on the King side so
this is where something should happen
and he immediately lashed out with F
form which ultimately does not let
anything great but there is not much
room here for black to prepare any
advances just for example if you look at
g5 as an example there's g4 and black
and basically resign yeah look at this
sewing the f porn now we'll move and
then you can simply take here with a
check even it's very tough for black to
do anything great in terms of preparing
the advances and so he just pushed f4
probably the right practical decision
yeah it's of course clear that white
shouldn't take this is immediately
turning the tables f3 coming the bishop
gets opened up just one to d2 and black
played in three of course just pushing
forward yeah but white has a good reply
just Bishop to e1 yeah and this Bishop
is now covering these are these these
captures yeah there is not much that
black n do he needs to take at one point
or it can play this kind of waiting
boosie a king a queen see one by the way
instead of this night f5 was also very
strong after G takes there is the
strongest reform and white also as much
better
but carla's move was good enough he
played Quincy one age five and now he
just took him yeah of course black took
on g three tools to really make it yeah
ought to sort of disturb the position a
bit more by on the white side but why it
still has very good pieces good night
the ruckus on the open file and those
bishops are also useful yeah II for just
very strong play again this is hanging
but it does not matter like took root d3
yeah the Queen needs to return they need
to got f5 this exactly was played and
after G takes f which is the normal move
really there was a strong reply ephone
yeah and everything's now working is
just like clockwork all pieces are
working harmoniously together f5 is a
tech now taking is completely check
completely acting so what should like do
if you advance there is no real threat
this look is covering f3 there's a
possible night f5 coming best movers
probably a queen d 1 by the way
attacking this and just asking black ok
what are you going to do I'm going to
play this or this and the black has no
active play really yeah takes check the
bishop takes and Queenie three strong
move centralizing the Queen intending
maybe Queen g3 to exchange them yeah the
whole position it's really so
problematic for black not because I mean
this is this is an additional problem is
a porn down but note that this Bishop is
not doing much and the knight on c6 is
also not doing much compare this to
those pieces they are just much more
active yeah the position also would be
quite quite terrible for black if you
let's say would add
upon on a seven for example and then
this would be equal material but the
position is just about about as bad it's
a only a slight consolation that you're
not a pawn down but the whole structures
the problem the the pawn structure
combined with with the pieces ok we need
three look f4 and the Bishop g2 back
yeah we are already in them in a phase
where Carlson just needs to display good
technical play keeping everything
together not allowing any counter play
enter as you would expect from him is
doing a great job here you tax the pawn
so black needs to lose some time and now
the big Queen side majority three
against one set into motion yeah if or
as a desperate move really but
understandable karana wants to use his
pieces and this is in fact happening
that the pieces get activated but just
by concrete play Carson is keeping
everything nicely together yeah here a
little technical shot tactical as almost
almost a bit a bit too big a word
because it's just this this pin that is
used here rookies hanging there for
black cannot take the pawn yeah the sea
porn is just very very strong there is
really no way for black to put up any
any more resistance now c7 is a concrete
idea yeah this is again not working
check down now we check see after the
number of checks that the sea porn is
ready to promote yeah kawana continued
for a couple of moves check getting in a
spy check at least but that's really not
doing anything here
he had to resign the game yeah the only
is one check left basically which can
always be um a always be answered by
Ruby one blocking the check so a
decisive win for Carlton in the in the
final round winning against his
co-leader kawana yeah what what can you
really a sum up for this game it was a
somewhat weird game in my book causal
played this tricky opening move order
that invites black to to capture and
play d5 but it also allows some some
creativity in a way and kawana he is he
spent lots of time here more than 20
minutes to play d5 and allowing this
this capture and after that we we got a
sharp interesting game Carlton has
managed again to to get an interesting
play without any big theory behind it
yeah what what surprised me is that
kawana didn't go for Nigeria which looks
like a pretty logical move to me trying
to force the recapture of the porn
instead he went here and after that I
think black needs to be very very
precise and in the decisive moment here
when we got to this spot here made this
mistake with f5 and after that it's it
really seems that white is clearly
better and Carlton just won a super
smooth game let's absolutely I tried
with a computer everything there is no
improvement for black it seems that he's
really almost lost him after a five very
very interesting development that blacks
position yeah fell apart so so quickly
so you how to sum up this tournament
intolerant victory for cards no had a
very weird middle of the tournament when
he suddenly lost those two games in a
row which was really a bit of a shocker
but well after that the second
he won three games yeah taking two full
points again from Nakamura and
mamedyarov against Nakamura he was in
huge trouble but he managed to win again
antia really played a great game when it
counted right here at the end he needed
to win this game to be the the sole
winner of the event and he managed and a
pretty convincing fashion karana really
never had anything great in this game so
we are congrats to the world champion
who again is winning a tournament yeah
second place goes to kawana with the
plus one score certainly am a
disappointing end to the event but still
plus one is not bad we got some players
on fifty percent kayaking by the way
played ten draws not too exciting he
even had played a couple of drawers in
the event before that I think the
Russian team championships or something
like that he's on I think 18 draws in a
row or something like that i read it on
twitter believe so quite quite we had
the only player can really totally
unsatisfied this Mammadyarov who really
made a big minor score so i'm not a good
event for him a job offer made a minor
come back here he was in very good shape
for a while beating carlson being on +1
but then he lost the game too hmm
trying to remember who who it was a good
job of lost against against carwin I
believe hope I'm not screwing this up
yeah well Nakamura I really am also
could have yeah it was close to a good
tournament he just needs to beat car
than once out of this great positions
that he has but he didn't didn't manage
all right i hope you enjoyed the
coverage of this tournament i think it
was an interesting tournament lots of
fighting chest unfortunately up until
the the very end of the event there was
no benoni plate to sort of honor the the
great lugar gashi waffles moyer this
tournament was after all yeah maybe they
should think of doing those kind of
events with with let's say predefined
openings just play the Benoni every game
or something would be funny so this way
we didn't see any of his favorite
opening yeah I'm not quite sure what
event it will be that I cover next term
on video I can tell you that I won't
cover the u.s. u.s. championships not
because it's an uninteresting event it
is an interesting tournament um but the
thing is I'm away about four botted
let's think about it nine or ten days
playing a tournament myself and yeah I
hope when I return that I can show some
of my games that are hopefully
interesting if you want to follow this
event it starts and about I think it's
11 days um played on the Mediterranean
island's of Majorca favorite destination
for German tourists yeah and if you want
to follow the event there is a page for
the tournament you need to click a bit
to get to it the starting page pages
winter chess calm yeah winter chess calm
they have a serious of turnham
then this is an open tournament starting
I think May eleventh if i'm not mistaken
so this is where you can can follow the
results at least and yeah i hope i
returned with some interesting games
okay thanks for watching I'll be back
soon bye